Let's be honest, your contribution to
the world so far is a browser history
you make sure no one sees. Incognito
tabs, deleted logs, hours gone, nothing
built. Now, contrast that with this. A
masjid is being completed in a village
in Norway where Muslims have nothing. It
will stand for generations. Those who
donate will be remembered by Allah. And
those who don't will quietly return to
the shadows, back to the consumption,
secrecy, and absolute nothing to show
for it. So, [music] do the right thing.
Post the video or click the link below
and donate for your own akhira.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh. How are you guys doing? Uh
welcome to another video wherein which
we are going to be deciphering,
assessing, analyzing some of the
statements online.
And we're going to be continuing the
theme from last week, the motif which
now
we're bringing forward. Uh where where
where in which I actually spoke about uh
Mehdi Hasan's discussion with Professor
Jang. And Mehdi Hasan responded in I'm
not sure if you can see this on the
screen right now or not, but I hope you
can.
Where he was, you know, saying, you
know, "Haven't you seen this this
video?" I'm paraphrasing of course, "But
haven't you seen this video where he's
speaking about Judaism and that starts
from Islam?" He also mentioned some
other things which uh which I responded
to. But
he made a point. Yes, uh Jang needs to
be refuted actually. Because he said
things about Islam which are
repudiable. They're easily confuted
actually. Let's take a look at what Jang
said here and come back and respond in
kind. And so, they keep on the fight
even though they've lost the war against
the Romans, they will go into the
Arabian desert where they will incubate
a new religion called Islam and they
will prophesize the coming of the
Messiah which turned out to be to be
Muhammad, right?
Um so, at this point in history, the
Jews must leave Jerusalem because the
Romans basically kicked them out and
their religion was splintered into into
many different factions.
Um and as we discussed, what will happen
is those Jews who are Muslim-like, they
will escape into the Arabian desert and
they will incubate Islam.
>> Well, as you can see, Jang is making
this claim, okay?
He's making the claim that Islam is an
offshoot or some kind of an outgrowth of
Judaism. Now, this claim is without
substance, frankly. And that is the
reason why you will not find a single
solitary
secondary source, okay, from even
Orientalist literature, okay? Even
Orientalist literature which kind of
substantiates what he's talking about.
Now, there are all kinds of in the
academy, in the Western academy, and
elsewhere. There are all kinds of
theories about early Islam. There are
many what you call historical exegetes,
people that try to
exegetically interpret the first, you
know, couple of centuries of Islam and
how the emergence of Islam is to be
explained, etc. These theories, which I
will be calling conspiratorial in this
case, these conspiratorial theories of
Mr. Jang is something which
unfortunately has not been even
substantiated or even said by anybody
else. So, the thing is, Jang, this is
the problem, okay? I don't consider you
to be a fraud. I'm just to be open with
you. I think you're a very intelligent
person. I think you have a lot to offer.
And listen, I've done six degrees. One
of them is in politics, okay? And I've
studied international relations. And
some of the things that you say, I
understand from an educated perspective,
I'd like to think.
are not actually stupid, okay? And I'll
come to that maybe at the end of what
I'm saying, but they're not stupid
because they're based on a
presupposition
which um is established in international
relations. I'll come to that after I've
dealt with this matter. The point is
this though, when you speak about
religion and theology and philosophy and
things, you make a lot of blunders and I
don't think you have a coherent
philosophy.
And that is why when you speak about
first of all the the beginnings of
Islam, you don't have anything
substantive. You don't have any academic
receipts. Look, the burden of proof is
upon the one that's making the claim. If
you're saying that Islam started from
Judaism essentially, it was kind of an
outgrowth from it, then you have to
provide some kind of a mechanism,
historical mechanism, that links A to B,
that links the Prophet Muhammad, for
example, to the Jews in this sense or
what kind of Jews and what you're
talking about and what kind of thing how
exactly is this passage
done? And and then the companions and
all these kinds of things.
You have to bring us the information of
that. But let's say if you can't do
that, that's not a problem.
Then you shouldn't be making these
claims, frankly. But it's not just your
historical exegesis which is spurious,
specious, or otherwise silly, frankly.
It's also your
theo-philosophical
outlook. Let's take a look at this clip
and come back and respond in kind. I
mean, basically, why would you not
consider yourself a Muslim? I have
issues with the Islamic faith, okay? My
major issue is that, you know, I I got a
lot of hate for my lecture, okay? But I
believe that religion, organized
religion, it changes over time. So,
maybe in the beginning, it it had
certain ideas, but but in order to
accommodate empire, in order to
accommodate politics, it shifted over
time to become much more conformist, but
become much more static. And I don't
like that. My sympathies are toward
[music] connection with God directly.
Right? So, rather rather have an
intermediary telling you what God
thinks, well, you should be able to feel
God in your heart. And and and and I
mean like people have said I'm a
Gnostic, you know, or I'm a Luciferian.
I you know, I I don't I don't know what
these terms mean, okay? But I I believe
that we're all individuals with a divine
spark in us. And so, we should be all
able to connect connect directly to God.
We should all be able to exercise our
imagination on our our intuition. In
this clip here, he he speaks about this
thing called the divine spark and
somehow this is meant to explain things.
The divine spark, from my reading, is it
seems to originate somewhere
in the Gnostic um
in Gnostic texts. Uh Gnostics were for
Christians at least, this heretical
group, okay? This heretical group that
emerged in the first sort of sec- first
and second centuries of Christianity.
Now, of course, um one man's heterodoxy
is another man's heresy. That's a
different issue for another day. But the
issue is this is that uh this is uh a
flawed theo-philosophical understanding
because you're combining opposites,
okay? If you say God is What is God?
Okay, God If you ask any religious
person or any philosopher of religion,
right? What What is God? Okay? At the
base, God is the foundation for all that
exists. It's the higher power, the
foundation for all this. It's a
necessary being. It's the independent
thing, the thing that everything depends
upon. And that God depends upon nothing.
That's what God is, you see?
Pre-eternal, post-eternal,
all-knowledgeable, all-powerful. That's
the conception of God understandable to
human beings, okay? So, when they say
God, that's what we mean. We're we're
talking about the necessary being. We're
talking about the independent being.
We're talking about the post-eternal,
the pre-eternal. We're talking about the
all-knowing, the all-powerful. That's
what we're talking about.
So, when you talk about a divine spark,
because when I had this conversation
with Jordan Peterson,
I had two conversations with Peterson.
One of them was one of the most I think
it's his the number one most viewed
thing on his entire channel, by the way.
So, people are interested in his
conversations.
I had this conversation with Jordan
Peterson.
And he he made the same reference. He
said the divine spark, the divine spark.
Now, I'm asking this, if divinity is
essentially
an unlimited thing, okay? Something
which is uh without any blemish and
something which is without any
impediment or limitation. And the human
being is all the opposite of that. Is is
limited.
How could there be a combination of
these two things? I mean, if we are to
understand this, if we have a divine
spark in us, in our essence, which is
actually God's essence inside of us,
then uh that means you're you're
combining contradictory opposites
because you have something which is
uncaused on the one hand, which is God,
uncaused, uh necessary. Then you have
something which is caused, corrigible,
dependent, etc. on the other hand. And
you're combining the two things
together. And what I find kind of
confusing is that you postulate this
idea, but then you negate
the Trinity. And this is quite similar
to the incarnation theory because you're
thinking about some how God became man.
This is the kind of justifications that
um that Christians would make about
that. Let's see what you say about the
Trinity. Right, but the weakness was
that the Trinity didn't make any sense
to you. Well, it to many people, even a
lot of Christians, right? It makes no
sense at all.
Well, why does the Trinity not make any
sense to you?
Right. Well, because
um
you know, we think through intuition,
right? So, like how how do we know
something is right? Well, we we know
something is right because it sounds
right, because it it's it connects with
us.
Right? But the entire point of the of
the Holy Trinity, okay, an idea that
three things can be
separate but connected. Things three
things that that are different from each
other can be can be at one at the same
time. It's meant to confuse you. It's
meant to create cognitive dissonance.
And when you And so, when you accept the
idea of the Trinity, the idea is that
now you open your portal to all sorts of
whatever crap propaganda that they they
want to instill in you as well. And
that's why the Holy Trinity is the very
basis of the Catholic religion. Now, of
course, I agree with you on the Trinity.
This is the argument I made to William
Lane Craig who's the foremost uh
philosopher of religion and obviously
theologian. Is it similitude of that is
the similitude of there being two
mothers to the to one child to one
child, all right? So, if you have two
ultimate creators
that essentially create the universe,
okay?
This one universe. The similitude of
saying that there is that is the same as
to say that there are two mothers that
basically give birth to one single
child. Now, that can't be the case
because responsibility ultimately has to
be given to one mother. Likewise,
responsibility ultimately has to be
given to one creator. So, there are ways
that you can show through imagery and
other ways
that the Trinity is false. And this
leads me to my
maybe final point for the day, which is
that
when you become popular online, okay, it
becomes tempting for you to speak about
things that you're not qualified to
speak about, okay, Jang. And this is uh
just to be fair because frankly, I
defended you last week. This week, I
have to repudiate some of what the
things that you've said.
And I don't mind having a conversation
with you, a good faith conversation with
you about some of the things cuz I
actually think that some of the things
that you say are very intelligent, okay?
What you say about when you actually
analyze the geopolitical situation from
an educated standpoint, I'd like to say
to you that it's not actually absurd in
any way, shape, or form.
We studied, for example, in university
the different competing theories in
international relations. Now, one of
these theories was
the realist theory, okay? It was called
the realist theory of international
relations. And it was associated with
the likes of John Mearsheimer, okay?
Who's very active now as well, actually,
and has excellent analysis. And Stephen
Walt, together whom, by the way,
authored an excellent book which, in a
way, almost predicts what's happening
today called the Israel lobby, okay? We
we had to read this book.
Uh and this was um
essentially contrasted This school of
thought was contrasted with other
constructivist and what you call liberal
institution um
uh schools of thought. And it seems to
be that the realist school of thought,
uh at least in my estimation,
was more powerful. Now, the reason I
bring this to your attention is because
just like you did prophesize in your own
way, okay?
In your own way, you prophesize that,
you know, there'll be a war and America
will lose the war, etc. So, did John
Mearsheimer say the same thing? But he
came at it from a similar perspective as
you. Now, you call it game theory.
You say that, okay, for example, you
have a zero-sum situation. Now, zero-sum
is there has to be one winner and one
loser, essentially, right? It's it's the
opposite of win-win where both people
can win.
That is the I mean, you're you're you're
simply articulating, okay? You're simply
articulating the realist international
relations framework,
which is the most established framework,
which, as I mentioned, is associated
with people like John Mearsheimer,
Stephen Walt.
You because that is exactly what they
say. I mean,
in the realist framework, they would say
that the main area of analysis is that
you have states which are
self-interested and survival is the the
ultimate predictor for
a particular state how that state will
behave
in contradistinction with, for example,
the liberal institutionists who say that
uh for example, collaboration would be a
bigger impact or having a bigger impact
in terms of predicting future behavior.
The realist turned out to be, I would
say, way more accurate uh as we can see
in our with the with the wars that
happening in the world
uh in terms of predicting future
behavior. Now, the point I'm making to
you, therefore, is
I don't think that your analysis is uh
fraudulent. I don't think that you're a
stupid man. I don't think you're a
fraud. I think you're a very intelligent
man. I think that you've you've clearly
you went to Yale. I think I believe you
went to Yale. You've done a English
language degree. Uh you've studied
Dante, you studied Dostoevsky, you've
studied, you know, whoever it may be
that you've studied all these great uh
authors.
And you've taken some of the ideas and
you
are able to make predictions of a
geopolitical nature, which are good.
However,
the fact is, you know, I wouldn't feel
comfortable speaking about something
which I'm not qualified in. And I think
that's something you should adopt
because frankly, that's when the
fraudulent will become a stronger case.
People say, "Well, this guy is a fraud."
Why? Because he's speaking about these
things without any peer-reviewed, you
know, access or it's not even
referencing peer-reviewed texts.
And then that's when your otherwise
intelligent, okay, geopolitical analysis
and excellent analysis on the world
scale will become
I would say it would actually become
tainted. So, yeah, don't speak about too
many things. Otherwise, I'd love to
speak to you, uh Jang.
Uh I'd love to speak to you. I don't
mind calling you Professor Jang as a
matter of courtesy. I mean, I practice
Brazilian Jiu-Jitsu, the gentle art. And
we call the coach professor. I mean,
it's not something I see as a big thing
as, "Oh, you know, you're you're a
fraud, you're a professor." You know,
you you're not a true professor. You
haven't done a PhD. You haven't got
Actually, the UK has a different
criterion of what is a professor
compared to the US, for example. Even in
those two countries, there's a different
criterion.
So, I don't think it's a huge deal, you
know? However, having said that, I do
think what is a big deal, and I have to
be honest with you here, is speaking
about religions and histories that
you're not familiar with, that you don't
have access to, that you haven't looked
at primary or secondary source details
of,
you haven't thought about properly, and
they're just coming out because people
are taking you seriously in one field,
you just assume they're going to take
you seriously. Because there are people
going to fact-check you, bro.
Over with due respect. And that's what
it is. There has to be a level of
intellectual humility, frankly. So,
that's it. I mean, I don't want to make
it too long. And with that, I conclude.
As-salamu alaykum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh. You probably don't deserve
to watch this video. Your level is
honestly too low to watch this video.
So, feel free to click away from the
video. But for the few who can handle
responsibility, we're building the only
masjid in a village in Norway. First
payment is already done. Final 500,000
remaining. Huge sadaqah jariyah waiting.
If you're serious about Islam, you'll
pause the video and you'll click the
link below to donate right now. If
[music] not, enjoy the comment section.